North Korea says it is still willing to
sit down with the US at any time after
President Trump pulled out of next
month's planned summit
North Korean state media called the move
unexpected and extremely regrettable the
president warned the north yesterday
about any military response and blame
Kim jong-un's government for his
decision I believe that this is a
tremendous setback for North Korea and
indeed a setback for the world our
military which is by far the most
powerful anywhere in the world that has
been greatly enhanced recently as you
all know is ready if necessary before
mr. Trump's announcement North Korea set
off large explosions at its nuclear test
site and claimed it was destroyed Ben
Tracy was the only u.s. broadcast
network correspondent to witness it he's
in once on North Korea Ben good morning
good morning we were actually in the
middle of a 12 hour train ride when we
got the news that the summit had been
cancelled and it was somewhat awkward to
be in the position of telling our North
Korean guides that news but frankly they
did not seem particularly surprised the
feeling here is that the u.s. is not
living up to its promises but that North
Korea by closing its nuclear site feels
that it is
this is what North Korea called
its commitment to peace in a series of
explosions the North claimed to destroy
its ones treasured poem Gary nuclear
testing site the regime has been testing
its nuclear weapons here since 2006
until now we have only seen this highly
secretive location from satellite photos
but a small group of international
journalists were allowed to tour the
facility before it was blown up so this
is the entrance to tone number 2 here at
North Korea's nuclear test site this is
where they have conducted five of their
six nuclear tests over the last couple
of years and you can see they have now
strung up explosives in there they plan
to blow this up so they can no longer
use it some outside scientists have said
this nuclear site was already so badly
damaged by previous tests that it was
not usable but during the nine hours we
were led around the grounds North Korean
officials stressed that two of the
tunnels were still operational and that
destroying them is a real concession so
they've told us we could come
double-check and see with our own eyes
that these tunnels have been destroyed
but these are all journalists here there
are no outside experts that can actually
verify that what they've done here has
made this site unusable we can only
confirm they blew up the entrances to
the tunnels if the tunnels inside the
mountain still exist this site could
potentially still be used for future
nuclear tests now the North Koreans
claimed that there was no radiation
leaked during these explosions and they
say they've never detected radiation at
the site however the one thing they did
confiscate from our luggage when we
arrived here in North Korea was the
equipment that we brought to detect
radiation Jon very interesting man
tracie inside North Korea thanks Ben